[Musique]
maman
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire projet de loi contesté
manifestation d'étudiants et
d'enseignants chercheurs labos de
recherche qui se déclarent en lutte
qu'est ce qui va mal dans l'université
française et pourquoi ces cas de censure
à répétition françois hollande alain
finkielkraut sylviane agacinscki
geoffroy le jeune sont empêchés de
parler mais aussi pour rien bouteldja ou
jean bricmont par les demo slam aux
phobies ou 2d colonialisme à la fac
devient de plus en plus difficile la
liberté d'expression est menacée de tous
les côtés pour en débattre nous avons
donc invité philippe blanchet vous êtes
professeur de sciences du langage à
l'université rennes 2 dont vous êtes
aussi le précisions du conseiller
academy vous venez de publier main basse
sur les i sur l'université aux éditions
textuel ou vous analysez les politiques
françaises d'enseignement supérieur et
de recherche depuis 30 ans
l'université a beaucoup changé qu'est-ce
qui la menacent aujourd'hui d'après vous
beaucoup de choses la menace mais l'une
des choses dans l'actualité qui la
menacent le plus c'est la mise en place
de politiques qui consiste à essayer de
les faire fonctionner comme des
entreprises et à mettre la main sur ce
qui s'y passe et ce qui s'y dit jean
bricmont vous êtes physicien vous avez
enseigné à l'université catholique de
louvain en belgique vous êtes l'auteur
avec alan sokal d' imposture
intellectuelle réédité en 2018 chedid
jacob dans lequel vous vous moquiez de
la façon dont nombre d'intellectuels
français utilisent un vocabulaire
scientifique sans rien y comprendre
vous êtes également l'auteur de la
république des censeurs qui est en cours
de réédition aux éditions jeanne sous un
autre titre les censeurs contre la
république avec un chapitre consacré à
la censure au sein de l'université
vous avez vous même été annulée invité à
l'université de nice sur le thème
comprendre la mécanique quantique votre
conférence a été annulée à la demande
d'associations vous accusant d'avoir
défendu des dégâts sioniste ou d'avoir
défendu dieudonné au nom de la liberté
d'expression c'est qu'est-ce qui
menacent l'université pour vous jean
bricmont
ce soir je suis là pour discuter de la
question de liberté d'expression mais je
dirais ça rentre dans un cadre plus
général qui fait que l'université sous
prétexte de s'ouvrir au monde au monde
de l'entreprise ou des associations etc
ou de donner un rôle excessif aux
étudiants en fait perd son autonomie est
pour moi l'autre ces deux conceptions
faussement libéral et faussement
progressiste de l'université et pour moi
l'université doit être justement en
obtenant par rapport à l'état aux
entreprises aux associations etc
mais si rare guénif souilamas cette
sociologue professeur à l'université
paris 8 vos recherches portent sur les
questions de genre d'ethnicité les
discriminations le racisme
vous avez assuré la codirection du livre
rencontre radical pour des dialogues
féministes des coloniaux aux éditions
cambourakis qu'est ce qui la menace
l'université d'après vous je pense que
les universités si ça continue va cesser
d'être un bien commun c'est à dire
quelque chose qui assure une éducation
notamment dans le supérieur à toutes et
tous sans distinction et sans
discrimination et par ailleurs je pense
qu'on est en train de parachever un
programme qui en fait a commencé il ya
déjà presque deux décennies et qui
semble consiste avant tout à vendre à la
découpe littéralement certains secteurs
de l'université parce qu'ils sont juste
parce qu'ils constituent des atouts
parce qu'ils peuvent devenir comptable
et d'autres seraient relégués en quelque
sorte pour assurer des formations qui ne
serait pas valorisé à des étudiants qui
ne serait pas non plus valorisées et
donc nous sommes face en fait un enjeu
qui est celui notamment de là
de la dégradation des conditions
d'études pour les étudiants ça c'est
quelque chose qui n'est absolument pas
assumer aujourd'hui en dépit d' du
sacrifice d'un étudiant qui s'est immolé
par le feu en neuf ans mois dernier et
donc ce à quoi nous assistons c'est la
fin d'un moment et le parachèvement
d'une volonté en fait de libéraliser à
outrance à tel point que effectivement
l'autonomie la liberté de la recherche
la capacité d'innovation et d'invention
tout cela risque d'être laminée par la
lame de fond qui consiste à démonétisé
les universitaires pour les mettre en
concurrence et les contraintes en
quelque sorte a montré qu'en fait ils
ont une valeur qui devient de fait non
pas une valeur scientifique mais une
valeur marchande
jean baptiste noël professeur d'histoire
à l'université catholique de l'ouest
rédacteur en chef de la revue conflit
vous avez été l'auteur vous êtes
l'auteur de rebâtir l'école plaidoyer
pour la liberté scolaire et de la non
mixité à l'école au delà du tabou pour
une idée aucune éducation innovantes les
deux sont parus aux éditions bernard
giovannangeli quels sont les problèmes
qu est-ce qui menacent universités la
mixité peut-être non non qui menace la
l'université c'est le manque de liberté
mais c'est pas nouveau ça date de jules
ferry et de l'imposition du monopole
scolaires notamment le monopole de la
collation des grades
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de liberté d'enseigner ya pas liberté de
pensée mais là aussi c'est un phénomène
qui ne date pas de maintenant qu'il ya
plusieurs décennies penser que raymond
aron par exemple avait du mal à exercer
librement son métier de professeur à la
sorbonne
donc c'est un mal qui est très ancien
qui peut être focalisée aujourd'hui sur
les événements de l'actualité des faits
très anciens qui est consubstantielle au
fonctionnement de myrtilles en france
alors commençons par les problèmes
justement de 2
de financement de tous ces problèmes
liés notamment à toutes les réformes qui
se sont succédé depuis 30 ans qu'est ce
que qu'est ce que ça a mené philippe
blanchet pour vous c'est on va de plus
en plus vers une privatisation
l'université oui on va vers une
privatisation de l'université de deux
façons d'une part en faisant entrer de
plus en plus le monde privé le monde de
l'entreprise dans l'université
toute une série de lois ont accentué
cette possibilité ces dernières années
mais aussi une privatisation en la
faisant fonctionner comme si c'était
comme si ça produisait quelque chose
qu'on pouvait vendre qu'on pouvait
marchandises et est du coup l'une des
choses qui est frappant c'est le fait
que l'état si on prend l'exemple de
l'université française d investir au
maximum c'est-à-dire considère que c'est
une charge que de s'offrir une
université de service public et au lieu
d'assurer des financements sur la durée
des financements stables à des
enseignants chercheurs et enseignants
chercheurs qui ont des situations
d'indépendance et de protection pas
avoir le temps de faire de la recherche
de réfléchir de débattre entre d'avancé
on les met sur
des systèmes de projet à court terme ce
qui fait que les enseignants chercheurs
aujourd'hui passent une bonne partie du
temps pour lequel ils sont payés à
monter des projets pour trouver de
l'argent pour faire le travail pour
lequel ils sont payés et c'est toujours
sur du court terme avec des critères qui
font qu'on va toujours donner plus à
ceux qui sont conformes
d'une certaine façon on va empêcher
l'innovation les choses bizarres au
début ben sont pas acceptés alors que
c'est par les trouvailles un peu
étonnante que souvent l'innovation
fonctionne et puis on va aussi
comme vous le disiez à l'instant un
haut-fond faire 2 université à deux
vitesses l'une qui serait l'université
dite d'excellence et un mot à la mode
qui capterait de plus en plus tous les
moyens qui seraient au sommet de la
pyramide parce que tout ça découle d'une
pensée de la société comme une pyramide
au lieu d'un système de solidarité
d'égalité
et puis on laisserait anbar relégué des
sous ou universités qui ne ferait qu'une
sorte d'enseignement secondaire un petit
peu supérieure et ou éventuellement
ferait même plus de recherche du tout le
conformisme si vous viviez
j'aimerais assez d'accord avec ce que
dit enfin moi je ne connais pas
l'université française mais en belgique
c'est que cette conception libérale néo
libérale si on veut qu'ils aient que
évidemment comme on est nommé une fois
qu'on est nommé on n'est pas très vite
dans 25 ans dénommé on était en position
très stable donc par hypothèse on en
profite pour ne rien faire
donc il faut vous surveillez donc il
faut faire des commissions ont fait des
commissions d'experts que de nous
évaluer etc
ces commissions prennent un sens inouï
on va faire des rapports que personne ne
lit et après on tient même pas nous
sommes en compte des recommandations des
commissions
et puis les commissions prennent le
temps de gens il faut prendre forcément
il faut prendre des gens principe plus
malin plus intelligent plus tout ce que
vous voulez pour juger les légendes dans
les universités donc on va perdre le
temps aussi de gens qui pourraient être
très productif mais qu'ils passent leur
temps à faire des évaluations
moi je suis d'accord qu'il faut évaluer
les gens mais dans le temps faisait
d'être de recommandations et puis voilà
pour les promotions pour tout ça c'était
pas une bureaucratie de l'évaluation
comme on a créé une aujourd'hui et c'est
ça qui est paradoxal dans la société
c'est que la croissance du libéralisme
ou de néo libéralisme va de pair avec la
bureaucratisation alors qu'ils
n'arrêtent pas de se plaindre
bureaucrates il ya tout là je pense que
sur l'évaluation c'est intéressant de
distinguer ce qui a était de plus en
plus exigée par une administration
bureaucratique et qui effectivement
cherche à détourner d'eux
de l'énergie qui est celle dans laquelle
tant de les enseignants-chercheurs
naturellement prolongé leur recherche y
compris sur des sujets qui peuvent
parfois sembler être controversé
et pourquoi pas et polémiques et
pourquoi pas c'est tout l'intérêt de la
recherche et 7,7
cette façon de focaliser est en quelque
sorte de contraindre les chercheurs à
faire un travail d'évaluation qui est de
plus en plus qui emprunte à une
novlangue qui qui a rase tout les toutes
les subtilités toute la complexité de ce
qui est produit
celle là évidemment tous les
enseignants-chercheurs et enchaîne une
chercheuse rechignent à la faire mais
par contre l'évaluation qui fait qu'on
lit des dossiers dans le cas d'une
commission pour recruter de nouveaux
collègues
personne ne rechigne à faire ça tout le
monde demande à le faire et là on voit
bien en quoi est-ce qu effectivement y'a
un régime complètement schizophrène
d'une certaine manière d'un côté on nous
empêche de faire avec tout le soin
nécessaire d évaluation qui ont une
véritable un objectif qui vont
contribuer à maintenir vivante et
vibrante la vie universitaire et on nous
contraint à faire des dévaluations qui
n'ont absolument aucun sens et qui d'une
certaine manière stérilise notre métier
jean baptiste noël j'ai l'impression que
pour vous le problème de l'université
c'est qu'elle est publique si elle était
privée
ça serait peut-être n'ont ni ni publique
ni privée ça c'est un fait une fausse
dichotomie
le problème c'est la question à liberté
parce que ce que vous avez vous enfin je
crois qu'on est tous d'accord sur la
bureaucratisation ça me rassure un petit
peu de savoir que ce problème n'est pas
que français mais qu'en belgique il ya
un peu de voilà ce qui montre que c'est
un phénomène qui dépasse largement le
cadre français et cette
bureaucratisation elle est partout et
qui est intéressant à voir c'est que le
l'université devient une sorte
d'enseignement secondaire bis et que
l'état et les mots du secondaire on le
retrouve aujourd'hui à l'université avec
par exemple l'arrivée de deux
conseillers pédagogiques qui sont des
personnes qui explique aux professeurs
d'université comment ils doivent
enseigner comment alors des gens qui
souvent d'ailleurs n'ont jamais eu de
l'étudiant en face d'eux et donc ils
leur apprennent comment faire cours à
des gens qui enseigne depuis parfois
vingt ou trente ans
et en fait on a une délégitimation
complète du professeur quels qu'ils
soient d'ailleurs d'université ou autre
est également une délégitimation aussi
de ce qu'est l'université et ça c'est un
phénomène qui est effectivement une
touche 20 bat largement au delà du cadre
français
vous êtes d'accord oui moi je dirais que
il ya une chose qu'il faut vraiment
avoir à l'esprit cette les universités
sont des lieux où avant tout on fait de
la recherche donc on élabore des
connaissances nouvelles et ou ensuite on
les enseignes et donc pour élaborer des
connaissances nouvelles il les
connaissances nouvelles il faut avoir
des conditions spécifiques à l'activité
scientifique dont l'indépendance des
pressions politiques des pressions
économiques des pressions idéologiques
et il ya toute une série de billets par
lesquelles ce qu'on appelle en gros le
néolibéralisme essayent de contourner
cette indépendance y compris en termes
de liberté d'expression spécifique des
universitaires en tout cas en france ils
ont un statut particulier pour justement
va essayer de transformer cette
université qui ne soit plus un lieu
intellectuellement indépendant mais un
lieu au service de leur projet de
société passé à la moulinette du même
projet de société que l'hôpital public
où les transports et ça n'a pas toujours
été le cas ça parce qu'on a toujours
tendance à penser que pas en france ni
mieux ou sont à mythifier le passé alors
en france on a en gros deux grandes
périodes ya une période qui s'ouvre en
46 avec la nouvelle constitution et qui
se clôt en 84 avec les loi savary est
justement ce décret portant statut
particulier des enseignants chercheurs
qui le moment où se met en place une
université qui est prévu par la
constitution comme étant une université
gratuite de service public et que l'état
a le devoir de faire fonctionner et
c'est dans le préambule de la
constitution de 46 et le conseil
constitutionnel l'année dernière s'est
encore appuyé sur cet article
comme vous le savez pour annuler la
disposition qui consistait à demander
des frais d'inscription extrêmement
élevés aux étudiants c'est dire que
c'est encore une valeur donc il ya cette
première partie qui est une
démocratisation de l'université
d'ailleurs on passe de deux cent mille
étudiants 1960 année
deux cent mille en 1981 et puis à partir
de 86,6 à la prom' premier projet c'est
la loi devaquet qui essaye de mettre en
place une université sélective davantage
payante et cetera
et depuis on voit régulièrement ensuite
il ya eu ben le processus de bologne et
puis le projet de loi raffarin qui a été
abandonnée devaquet aussi a été
abandonné comme vous le savez et on
revient tout le temps à l'attack puis la
lru qui elle a réussi à passer
et puis depuis le gouvernement actuel en
tout cas en france toute une série de
dispositions les ordonnances dérogatoire
de décembre 2018 le projet de loi de
programmation pluriannuelle pour la
recherche qui cherche justement à
contourner cette espèce de bastion
d'indépendance intellectuelle l'une des
façons les plus connus sébacées
l'étranglement budgétaire on donne plus
assez d'argent
donc on oblige des universités a joué le
jeu pour en trouver et puis c'est la
création de nouveaux statuts précaires
contractuels de deux chercheurs et
d'enseignants chercheurs qui n'ont qui
ne bénéficient plus de ce statut
d'indépendance avec la liberté
d'expression qui est assorti dans le
régime français c'est une statut
constitutionnel et donc on voit qu'on
essaye de contourner cet îlot jusqu'à ce
qu'on réussisse à le faire tomber
oui à la liberté d'expression elle a été
elle était rarement présente à nous
acheter français lille ne faisait pas
bon ne pas être communiste dans les
années 50 60
donc les phénomènes qu'on a aujourd'hui
ne sont pas nouveaux pour la discipline
qu'est la benne à savoir la géopolitique
vous avez une grande conférence à la
sorbonne en 1950 qui a interdit la
géopolitique au motif que les nazis
ayant lui un auteur de géopolitique dont
d'ailleurs la femme était morte à dachau
et le fish et participer au concours de
stauffenberg fin avait avait estimé que
c'était une science nazis donc l'ont
interdite et donc encore aujourd'hui la
géopolitique est une discipline qui est
interdit de l'université même si elle
revient parfois par des travées de deux
de secours
donc il ya toujours eu une chape de
plomb qui a pesé
avec notamment par l'intégration des
professeurs à l'université qui fait que
ça n'a jamais été véritablement un lieu
d'innover afin de réelle liberté
d'expression le il y a toujours manqué
un grand pluralisme à l'université
française et d'ailleurs c'est la raison
pour laquelle elle est en train de
disparaître
il ya aussi lire un sujet que ça qu'on a
pas encore évoqué on en parle parce que
quoi que cette émission mais ce sont les
étudiants dire que les étudiants ils
font des choix quand ils sont en
terminale ou ailleurs et l'étudiant voit
bien c'est les établissements qui
fonctionne ce qui ne fonctionne pas là
où il ya des blocages levés n'a pas ils
vont vers ceux qui leur offrent des
débouchés des métiers et l'étudiant
choisit ce qui a tord ou à raison qu'il
paraît être quel meilleur jeune et ses
acteurs rationnels l'étudiant de
l'opération il fait des choix ressembler
ou pardon s'il vous plaît vous semblez
oublier que dans le système français
la logique d'orientation elle est de
plus en plus sélective je rappelle qu'il
ya eu parcours sub qui fait partie du
même lot de réformes que parcours sup
est de plus en plus une instauration
d'un mode sélectif
donc on a pas on n'a pas à faire un
acteur rationnelle dont on nous parle
beaucoup aussi dans l'économie
néolibérale
on a affaire à des personnes qui sont
sous des logiques de contraintes
quels sont les établissements dans
lesquels elle de tels quels sont les
types de bakel ont passé avec combien
d'années de retard même si elles ont un
bac général
je rappelle que tout le monde a l'air
d'oublier ces éléments là donc les ags
les étudiants l'étudiant n'existe pas
nous sommes face à un monde extrêmement
hétérogène qui a d'ailleurs été de plus
en plus une hiérarchie zay qui n'a pas
forcément accès aller aux établissements
auxquels ils pourraient prétendre
et donc ces éléments la montre
qu'effectivement il ya un problème
central aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya une
aggravation des hiérarchies au sein des
étudiants et des étudiantes de la même
manière qu'il ya une aggravation de la
hiérarchie au sein des enseignants
chercheurs au sein des établissements
entre les établissements entre les
formations s'est tous azimuts
bien sûr c'est un monde de plus en plus
clivée outre de plus en plus sauvage je
suis désolé et moi je voudrais insister
sur un point
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure les étudiants
notamment par rapport à cet étudiant qui
s'est immolé en oeuvre
donc ça ça donne une figure emblématique
de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
l'autre élément il me semble c'est que
le moment où ces réformes se passe si au
moment où vous avez évoqué la
démocratisation la massification qu'on
connaît bien en sociologie de
l'éducation
sauf que tout le monde voit ça de plus
en plus comme une massification et de
moins en moins comme une démocratisation
donc en fait il faut gérer des nombres
et je rappelle qu'il ya quand même ça
coïncide avec un phénomène eux on a
souvent tendance à oublier en france
mais que je voudrais souligner puisque
c'est des éléments sur laquelle je
travaille depuis longtemps c'est que
c'est aussi l'arrivée dans le milieu
universitaire comme dans la société
française de toute une des générations
entières qui sont multi culturel
c'est-à-dire qui amène avec elle
d'autres histoires d'autres récits
notamment les récits coloniaux
postcoloniaux les récits de minorités
ethniques de minorités qui ont été
marginalisés qui ont été ségrégué
notamment dans les quartiers
disqualifier les quartiers démunis et
c'est aussi ce mode là qu'ils arrivent à
l'université j'ai enseigné à
villetaneuse et à saint denis
je peux vous dire que je les ai vus de
près depuis 20 ans ça aussi c'est
quelque chose qui en fait fait l'objet
d'une attaque dans le cadre de ces
réformes
parce qu'on considère que ces étudiants
et étudiantes là il ne mérite pas
d'avoir les mêmes formations que les
autres et ils devraient s'estimer déjà
heureux de pouvoir entrer à l'université
donc cette manière de les valoriser elle
instaure au sein même du monde
universitaire une logique qui est une
logique de persistance d'une perception
coloniale de la société française qui
s'impose au sein même de l'université
aujourd'hui hélas lppr sous ses airs
d'acronymes complètement innocent elle
introduit aussi cela de façon légale de
façon définitive à l'université donc
c'est aussi contre cela qu'il faut
lutter en prétendant justement aller à
l'encontre de saint louis compte de
remarques parce que si les étudiants
vont vers les études où il ya le plus
d'emplois alors il faut m'expliquer pour
gagner de telle masse d'étudiants qui
vont en socio psycho aussi en sports et
c'est plutôt conscience alors que là on
manque d'étudiants mais déjà on en a
tellement pas de problème pour trouver
un emploi
l'autre problème qui est réel dans
l'université celle extraordinairement
bas niveau des étudiants qui sortent du
secondaire et ça c'est vrai en belgique
comme en france
et dans mes collègues français enfin
vous qui travaillent en france se
plaignent et donc ça c'est un problème
qui n'est pas celui d'une université je
ne pense je ne sais pas comment le
résoudre parce qu'il vient d'en bas et
tout le système scolaire étant en crise
et finalement pour vous rassurer ok dans
un des cinq ans peut-être que dans cette
industrie française
c'était difficile de ne pas être
communisme vous assurer qu'en belgique
dans mon université c'était très facile
ou sainte bazeille communiste est très
difficile de l'être en angleterre dans
la plupart des pays d'europe où l'anti
communisme était pratiquement
l'idéologie dominante et communisme
fanatiques et donc moi j'ai connu ça
parce que j'ai grandi dans la belgique
catholique franco ce que vous dites sur
le niveau est tout à fait juste c'est
que on a une baisse générale qui se
constate dans le secondaire et après on
a beaucoup de mal à le rattraper en
licenciant master et savait qu'à partir
du moment où on diminue les gens du bas
qui ont fait croire que tout le monde
peut avoir le bac général
eh bien on a des populations qui arrive
en licence et qui ne font pas du tout au
niveau et est malheureusement il ya une
sorte de mensonges qui était
institutionnalisé
on donne le bac à des gens qui sont
méritants qui ont travaillé mais qui
n'ont pas les éléments
maîtrise linguistique autres il ya un
nombre de fautes d'orthographe kiki
faramineux et ensuite ces personnes là
et bien vous munissant c'est long un
master mais enfin les lacunes demeurent
ils ont du mal à comprendre pourquoi ne
trouve pas un métier pourquoi elles sont
pas embauchés et c'est souvent des
lacunes qui quelques cumuls et le
problème de l'université vous avez
raison de souligner que c'est d'abord et
avant tout un problème de l'école
primaire du du collège du lycée et c'est
là que ça se joue parce qu'une fois
après à 18 ou 20 ans est très difficile
de rentrer à la maison quel niveau qui a
baissé dans les enquêtes pisa le montre
un jeu de dire ça fait des années ça
fait presque deux décennies que la
france est très mal classés dans les
enquêtes de l' ocde sur la capacité
effectivement amené au meilleur de leurs
de leur talent et de et de leurs
compétences les élèves dans le système
scolaire français donc que cela se
répercute ensuite à l'université qu'il
faille avec différents programmes qui
sont un peu des dispositifs marginaux
compenser la difficulté que
qui s'est installé durablement dans le
système français personne personne n'en
disconvient le problème c'est comment
parvenir à réanimer les différents
niveaux de l'éducation en france de
façon à ce que ce qui a été mal fait ou
qui n'a pas été correctement corrigées
au sein de l'enseignement primaire et
secondaire ne se répercute pas au niveau
de l'enseignement supérieur et à
l'évidence la solution ce n'est pas de
sanctionner l'enseignement supérieur et
de décider qu'il va y avoir des
établissements à deux vitesses c'est à
dire des établissements d'excellence et
puis ceux où va après la relégation dans
les établissements qui sont ségrégée on
va les mettre dans des universités
ségrégée qui seront elles aussi relégué
fait place hélas hélas hélas pu on
pulvérise toute capacité à vivre
ensemble dans un tel contexte moi
j'ajouterais deux choses à ça la
première c'est que la réussite
universitaire est très difficilement
prédictible j'ai beaucoup de collègues
qui ont qui sont d'anciens très mauvais
élèves y compris parce que beaucoup des
disciplines qui sont enseignées à
l'université n'existe pas dans le
secondaire et qu'on a des méthodes de
travail qui correspondent peut voir
parfois pas du tout à la façon dont on
enseigne dans le secondaire ce qui pose
d'ailleurs un vrai problème avec
parcours super où vous avez des
collègues du secondaire qui se retrouve
obligé de donner des avis sur la
capacité à réussir de leurs élèves dans
de nouvelles disciplines avec de
nouvelles méthodes qu eux-mêmes ne
connaissent pas et donc ça paraît assez
aléatoire d'ailleurs beaucoup sont très
mal à l'aise avec ça donc moi je pense
qu'il faut faire aussi attention au fait
que quelqu'un qui n'a pas bien réussi ou
que l'école n'a pas bien réussi à amener
à la réussite parce qu'il faut partager
les responsabilités jusqu'au niveau du
bac peut-être que finalement pas cette
personne va se révéler après faut lui
laisser sa chance mais laisser sa chance
aux gens ça veut dire se donner les
moyens de les accompagner
ça voudrait dire effectivement première
année au cours du parcours de licence
les trois premières années
avoir des moyens importants
d'accompagnement pédagogique mais ça
veut dire avoir tout bêtement aussi
suffisamment d'enseignants avec de
suffisamment petit groupe
quand on vous pensez qu au jour en fin à
ces dernières années les effectifs
étudiants françois augmenté de 20% mais
qu'on a perdu deux mille postes
d'enseignants chercheurs et 1500 postes
de chercheur au cnrs vous
vous voyez ce qui se passe dans mon
département à l'université est un
département très attractif communication
qui accueille beaucoup d'étudiants on
était l'année dernière
un enseignant chercheur pour 83
étudiants alors évidemment avec ça
comment voulez vous aider les étudiants
qui aurait quelques difficultés et on
peut comprendre qu'ils en aient donc
c'est aussi avoir un vrai projet
politique avoir une ambition ça on est
vraiment un service public
d'enseignement supérieur et on essaye
d'accompagner le plus de jeunes possible
à l'éducation la plus élaborée la plus
développée possibles soit on abandonne
cette ambition là et on retombe dans ses
systèmes sélectif on a besoin d'en
enlever c'est pour ça qu'on met en place
parcours sup pour se réduire sur les
meilleurs qu'on sera probable est
meilleure sur le plan scolaire qu'on
sera probablement plus à même de faire
réussir sur le plan universitaire on va
passer à la aux entraves à la liberté
d'expression qui existent aujourd'hui
dont l'université mais juste une
question très rapide parce qu'il nous
reste moins d'une minute
le nouveau bac on est notée toute
l'année au sein de son établissement
est ce que les élèves est ce que les
professeurs qui vont noter des élèves de
l'établissement vont pas les surnoté où
les souris mais on ne sait pas après on
a envie que son établissement ont
surnoté non il ya des sujets les
corrections sont en accès libre
donc les étudiants je ne donnerai pas
les noms des sites ont parlé d'union et
lycéens peuvent très bien trouver les
sujets qui sont données ainsi que les
corrections et le professeur peut très
bien lien vers l'est tel chapitre avec
tech ou partie il était étudiant sait de
quoi il s'agit c'est se faufiler par les
dérobades généralise le bachotage qui
était déjà petit on fait une pause et on
transmet bas
[Musique]
il faut bien comprendre que les champs
de schiste pétroliers américains donc
quelques temps vont s'arrêter de
produire je voulais toutes les données
pétrolières sont confidentielles
est ce qu'on peut imaginer qu'à terme
avec le pétrole de schiste les
américains soient énergétique
indépendant banon ils sont en train de
frôler indépendance mais pour le gars
cynisme en mai pour le pétrole
non c'est puis là le puits de gist sont
des puits qui donne le maximum
les premiers mois après c'est une chute
continuelle
si les pétroles de schiste des cent
cette année suffisamment pour que ça
soit notable en moins novembre et rome
ne s'est pas pareil
[Musique]
à
ou est-ce qu'on en est au niveau de la
radicalisation dans l'espoir que le
terme radicalisation c'est un peu un mot
valise et ont même beaucoup de choses
qui ne reflète pas la réalité lampard de
la radicalisation islamiste dans le
sport c'est tout ce processus qui peut
conduire quelqu'un à se mettre en marge
totale de la société parfois même
basculer vers l'action violente en 2016
- sportif considéré que c'était pas son
affaire et qu'il n'avait pas à être une
sorte de délateurs des pouvoirs plus
parce que le sujet c'est qu'aujourd'hui
toute une série de phénomènes nous
échappe
ce sont ces associations qui se créent
ou bien des structures qui secret en
dehors du mouvement organisé certains
ont dit le sport amateur c'est le
premier lieu vecteur de radicalisation
c'est faux c'est la prison dans les
clubs
il peut y avoir des cas de prosélytisme
mais pas contre les radicaliser ne vont
plus à la mosquée ne sont plus à l'école
ne sont plus dans les clubs retirer vos
de la tête que le sport à six a dit il
[Musique]
on prend notre débat sur qu'est-ce qui
menacent universités avec figue blanche
et qui est professeur de sciences du
langage et qui vient de publier ma base
sur l'université avec jean bricmont qui
est physicien et qui republie ressort
plus exactement aux éditions jeanne les
censeurs contre la république
nacira guénif souilamas ce qui est
sociologue qui a co-dirigé rencontre
radical pour des dialogues féministes
des coloniaux aux éditions cambourakis
et jean baptiste noël qui est professeur
d'histoire qui est l'auteur de la non
mixité à l'école au delà du tabou pour
une éducation innovantes parlons alors
de ces ces entraves à la liberté
d'expression à l'université qui ne cesse
de se qui se multiplie conférences
annulées
chahuté pétition sujet tabou parole
surveillé alors ça dessine est allé dans
les médias que lorsqu'il s'agit de
françois hollande de sylviane agacinscki
ou 2 ou 2
qui c'est arrivé c'est les points quand
quelques semaines avant alain
finkielkraut florian philippot par
exemple a été interdite de au même
endroit qu'elle un finkielkraut florian
philippot n'a pas pu s'exprimer
hook ans et houria bouteldja ou
pensez-vous jean bricmont dont la
conférence sur l'aide de la physique
quantique est annulé à l'université de
nice au prétexte que vous seriez un
défenseur des négationnistes ou
d'antisémite
en général on vous traite d'ailleurs de
négationnisme ou d'antisémite alors que
jamais je peux le dire parce que j'en ai
cherchés il n'y a jamais eu de texte de
vous ni antisémite et négationniste ni
même complotistes sa maman vous avez
toujours vous avez toujours défendu au
sens vous ne voulez pas qu'il y ait de
poursuites pénales pour des délits
d'opinion ça c'est donc uniquement au
nom de la liberté d'expression vous
manifester et et que par la même
occasion on vous la retire mais alors
comment l'expliquez vous comment se
fait-il qu'aujourd'hui quelqu'un comme
vous quelqu'un aussi comme sylviane
agacinscki ne puisse plus s'exprimer à
l'université oui mais je mettrais
expliquer un peu ce qui est arrivé dans
mon cas c'est à dire le 26 et le 28 mai
passé j'étais à l'université nice est
arrivée la veille et je le décès d'un
ami il m'a dit voilà ton séminaire ne
pas avoir lieu pourquoi on ne savait pas
que tu défends la liberté d'expression
puis rencontrer mes collègues que vous
défendez la liberté d'expression ils
vous ont dit ça comme ça vous défendiez
la liberté 2 sur wii 2 du doigt de dieu
dauphin richard évidemment pas certaine
de données compagnie d'ailleurs c'était
dans l'émission dernière fois qu'on
s'est vue pratique france était à 6 ans
dans l'émission ce soir ou jamais bon
c'est un peu ce soir et plus jamais ou
la liaison sur dieudonné là ça a été
extrêmement houleuse
vous avez été attaqué par la suite
caroline fourré avec son sens de la
nuance habituel à dire chez taddeï ces
cinq minutes pour les juges et milite
pour hitler donc est clair c'était
monsieur l'abbé moi même pas sûr qu'il
serait représentants d'être représentée
par non enfin bref
donc on me dit voilà alors moi j'étais
vraiment choqué je veux dire vous avez
eu un débat il ya quelques jours avait
consigné le monsieur réal jeunes annulé
l'oci et oui c'est ça aussi mais quand
le jeune a dit qu'il fallait mettre en
prison des fichiers est ce qui est un
truc administratif consigny comme avocat
a dit mme alors moi c'est comme ça je
m'en vais et c est quand on m'a dit que
mon séminaire été annulée moi je me dis
mais comment est-ce possible j'ai été en
eut rejeté en chine j'étais au maroc
j'étais là je n'ai aucun problème pour
jamais pensé qu'on a annulé un séminaire
de physique dans ces pays pour des
raisons politiques
or en france pays des droits de l'homme
patati patata on le fait et moi ça m'est
égal ce n'est pas mon cas particulier
parce que j'ai pu parler avec mes
collègues par la suite un peu quand
destine lancé c'est pas ça c'est le
symbole et c'est le symbole que c'est
quelqu'un qui intervient un certain
david nakache qui intervient deux points
de vue totalement indépendant
l'université n'est pas moins de
l'université ne travaille pas
d'université ils travaillent dans les
alpes de haute provence chez papa et
je lui ai serré la tension de saïdi
voilà vous avez je demande des
explications universités donnait rien à
demander si j'étais d'extrême droite ce
que je prétend ne pas être maintenant je
suis catalogué j'aurai le droit de
parler physique
moi j'ai connu un mathématicien très
connu qui disait être en plaisantant que
si le pen était élue islamistes à
culture dire de la personne n'a dit il
peut pas parler de match
d'accord bon moi j'ai jamais dit ça non
plus donc je dire c'est complètement
surréaliste cette histoire et c'est pas
que il n'y a pas que moi d'abord y'a pas
que mon cas il ya monsieur philippe
souaille qui devait dans les cours se
régale université toulouse
il est membre la manif pour tous et eu
des tracts de groupes lgbt etc qui ont
dit oui on persécute on nous tue un peu
partout etc
du coup on a supprimé son cours mais oui
d'abord la manif pour tous nous
rappellent sûrement pas tuer qui que ce
soit numéro un et numéro 2 je vois pas
comme un encours sur lesquels va mettre
en péril la vie des gens c'est comme un
jeu restrictif et un autre monsieur qui
lui pour le cas le coût est vraiment
d'extrême droite des actions françaises
etc
elie hatem il donnait des cours de droit
administratif donc nous avons un truc
non politiques à l'université paris xiii
du nom des étudiants juifs de france est
venu avec des médiateurs magnétophone et
a reproché aux profs de ne pas s'être
présenté aux étudiants savoir pas
expliquer ses positions politiques c'est
exactement ce qu'il doit faire
dans les cours j'ai jamais parlé
politique jamais donné mes opinions
politiques c'est exactement ce qu'il
doit faire
on lui reproche et du coup son cours est
supprimé alors si on accepte que des
groupuscules lgbt féministe indigènes
juifs quoi que ce soit puisse faire la
loi dans les universités alors on peut
fermer la boutique
et vous me parlez des médias alors c'est
très bien parce que mon ami alan sokal
avec qui j'avais écrit imposture
intellectuelle a rédigé une lettre de
congé dit said a rédigé une lettre de
protestation qui a été signé par chomsky
ou et part samedi mais c'est ça ça va
partiellement une bière qui est un prix
nobel de physique par peggy sastre par
gérald bronner en france pardo qui est
parée par pink heures et qui a été
soumise est refusé au monde au figaro au
point
à marianne et un mediapart non c'est
comme une forme d un grand scientifique
et ça déjà ça ne prennent parti pour
vous vous défendent en disant ce n'est
pas le message qu'on dit caetera et les
journaux refuse de le passer de preuves
et de paraître oui alors évidemment ça
ça donne quand même une idée de la delà
de la situation en france
et moi je pense qu'il ya un effet
désastreux de cette situation pour la
pensée même en occident c'est que
puisque après tout c'est pas des champs
des thèses d'extrême n'était pas une
idée une condition de possibilité pour
exprimer les idées bon et à cause de ce
terrorisme intellectuel toute une série
de thèmes ne peuvent être abordés et il
ya des thèmes légitime vous pouvez même
être radical vous parler du climat où
vous parlez la construction européenne
qui est trop lente
l'antisémitisme des jeunes de banlieue
le racisme des français tout ça c'est
autorisé mais si vous intéresser aux
conflits internationaux à la politique
internationale que vous mettez en
question notre politique qui de mon
point de vue est absurde on va discuter
ce soir vis-à-vis de l'iran la russie de
la série la chine etc
c'est très très délicat il est
immédiatement accusé de soutenir
dictateur patati patata et évidemment
d'immigration c'est aussi un thème tabou
d'islamophobie
alors il yad'autres l'antisémitisme
l'islamophobie
c'est des choses qui sont difficiles à
discuter enfin je veux dire il ya des
tas de deux thèmes qui à mon avis ont
beaucoup les différences génétiques
entre méforme par exemple aussi très
difficile d'en discuter à cet événement
ça change un petit peu venant tout droit
quand j'étais plus jeune de ces d'en
discuter avec les gens sciences humaines
c'est impossible et donc c'est c'est on
se rend pas compte jusqu'à quel point
pour moi ça c'est le signe du déclin de
l'occident parce que la possibilité d
esprit critique
c'est ce qui a fait notre force dans le
passé pour le meilleur et pour le pire
et c'est en train de disparaître
maintenant je dois dire qu'il n'ya pas
qu'eux en france parce que je ne vais
parler de la liberté d'expression à
l'académie royale en belgique
bon c'est pas un endroit et j'ai
frissonné discrédit des crapules comme
vous ne mérite qu'une seule chose une
balle dans la tête sans procès c'est
qu'on est à la mode
si vous voulez vous pouvez avoir en
belgique aussi mais est partout où je
vais après l'émission
donc je vous remercie de membres invités
sur des données mais après des gens me
disaient que tu comprends on peut
partager t on alors comme invitée
régulièrement je veux dire ça a été un
truc quelques réalisations vous n'aviez
pas pris la défense des propos de
dieudonné et en plus il joue il joue il
est il fait une tournée dans toute la
france si c'est la fin de la république
alors il faut l'empêcher de faire sa
tournée pas m'empêcher de parler d'eux
et des géosciences de l'étiage de
physique relais les poursuites pénales à
son encontre
nacira guénif souilamas c'est pensez
vous alors en fait j'ai eu à essuyer ce
genre de de péripéties au cours de ma
carrière et notamment j'ai été désinvité
d'un colloque en allemagne par des
collègues sociologue qui n'ont pas
souhaité que je fasse une des
conférences plénières parce que j'étais
identifié comme antisémite et partisane
de bds boycott désinvestissement
sanctions contre contre l'état d'israël
donc ce sont des choses qui se passent
dans le secret
d
des conversations je n'ai jamais rendu
public parce que je ne voulais pas
mettre en difficulté les deux collègues
qui m'avait invitée et qui ont subi des
pressions de leurs milieux académiques
en allemagne
donc ce sont des choses qui arrivent
régulièrement en fait sont la question
est de savoir si et là en l'occurrence
voilà effectivement ça fait partie des
sujets qui fâchent
de quoi va-t-on parler donc moi ce qui
m'inquiète en fait c'est la difficulté
qu'on peut avoir aujourd'hui à établir
les les espaces d'une controverse et
d'une polémique qui soit fructueuse pour
tous la capacité à admettre que des
points de vue puissent s'exprimer qui
heurte les sensibilités et notamment
lorsque ses sensibilités
elle renvoie en fait à un point de vue
qui a été dominant qui a toujours été
très installé qui a pu prospérer en tout
confort et en toute tranquillité et puis
qui se voit contesté par de nouvelles
voies par de nouvelles interprétations
et pour ma part moi ce à partir de quoi
je réfléchis à ces questions là c'est
les questions d'islamophobie c'est la
question des colonials c'est les
questions de la remise en cause la
suprématie blanche et de la supériorité
occidentale et dans ce domaine là aussi
énormément de paroles qui sont réduites
au silence mais cette gestion de la
suprématie blanche et des dominants
d'autrefois blanc hétérosexuel s'était
fait qu'on va interdire astra tant de
gens de parler en disant qu'ils ont bien
trop parlé avant qu'il faut qu'ils
arrêtent de parler maintenant c'est
arrivé vers doublement aussi bien elle
affirme que le cre otcqx a qu'à françois
hollande
c'est au nom de cela qu on a essayé de
les faire taire mais en fait moi ce que
je trouve dommage dans cet essai qu'on
leur donne une publicité supplémentaire
en les interdisant de
de prise de parole si ça vous avez vous
aimé voilà vous avez peut-être subi
parce que parce que les gi mollet les
prises de les prises de position vous
avez pu vous en coûter cher mais il ya
des personnes qui bénéficient
particulièrement fin juillet franchement
françois hollande
ça lui a fait de la pub lorsqu'il a été
et ça s'est passé dans un contexte bien
précis
donc il ya des fois où on peut dire
effectivement ces personnes seront
réduites au silence non en fait elles
sont pas réduites au silence elles ont
une marge de manoeuvre ils ont une
surface d'influencé tels que c'est pas
parce qu'elles sont interdites de prises
de parole une fois que leur voix va
s'éteindre dans dans l'ensemble du ca
périgueux s'est pas reproduit tout à
fait mais est ce que je fais ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'au choc
le principe être tout à fait choquant
par contre tout le monde n'en tire pas
les mêmes bénéfices il en subit pas les
mêmes conséquences et je pense que ça
serait beaucoup plus intéressant de
regarder ensuite comment est ce que tout
ça se joue dans un contexte ensuite deux
légitimités jolie déviation a décrit les
médias s'offusque quand françois
l'africain croûte qui sont interdits de
parole il ne s'offusque pas quand c'est
florian philippot quand ces gens
brillement en plus caen et cette lettre
qui n'est pas public mais je n'ai par
exemple monsieur jean michel aphatie qui
est quand même un journaliste on va dire
relativement meanstream il a fait une
remarque très juste il a dit quand tu
donnes été condamné pour je ne sais pas
dit enfin peu importe les condamner pour
ce qu'ils avaient dit plus aucun média
n'a l'a accueilli et quand comment dire
algérie zemmour était condamné il était
partout et donc des censures faut
mentionner qu'il appelle censure
promotionnels depuis des sanctions
effectives
grâce à vous maintenant la censure dans
mon cas va peut-être être un peu plus
connu il était connu évidemment parce
que l réseaux sociaux les gens se
parlaient tout ça mais ce n'est pas
discuté en place publique parce que
voilà pas sur le fond on ne discute pas
de ça sur le fond c'est à dire qu'est ce
qui a amené à des formes de crispation
qui font que l'espace des discussions
possibles se rétrécit en fait qu'il ya
des thématiques c'est terrible qui sont
devenus de plus en plus
sulfureuse d'autres qui sont sur famille
d'emblée on ne peut même plus se
défendre de pseudo qu'on vous accuse en
l'occurrence dans ces occasions mais
c'est ce que moi personnellement le plus
choquant c'est qu'on ne puisse pas se
défendre de ceux d'autres non
si vous avez des antisémites c'est
terminé tout juste derrière on vit dans
une société qui est plus en plus dur je
pense que beaucoup de choses qu'ils
organisent l'organisme pour qu'elles
soient de plus en plus dur y compris
l'esprit de compétition où il y en a qui
doivent gagner y en a qui doivent perdre
et donc il ya des relations verticales
qui essaye de se mettre en place et où
cet espace de deux controverses mais de
controverses courtoise et intelligente
s'amenuisent de plus en plus et on
essaye presque d'empêcher qu'il existe
et donc je pense qu'il se passe là ce
qui se passe dans le reste de la société
c'est-à-dire un durcissement des
relations humaines et des relations
sociales
et puis par ailleurs ce dont on parle je
trouve c'est un exemple ce sont des
exemples intéressants parce qu'ils sont
à l'interface d'une manière ou d'une
autre d'ailleurs de manière qui peuvent
être très différentes dans votre cas où
dans le vôtre ils sont à l'interface
entre ce qui relève des débats entre
spécialistes entre chercheurs et ce qui
relève de débat public avec le reste de
l'ensemble de la société dont évidemment
il faut pas que l'université soit coupée
mais en même temps donc dont il faut
qu'il soit 1 qu'elle soit un peu
protégés et c'est sur ces zones
interface qui a des problèmes importants
et y compris et surtout dans les
sciences humaines et sociales parce que
par définition elle traite de ce qui se
passe chez les humains et dans les
sociétés
donc elle touche à des questions qui
sont aussi politiques idéologiques et
c'est même si elle les traite d'un point
de vue qui n'est pas nécessairement
politisé et que ce soit quelque 6 qu'on
empêche de s'exprimer dans universités
quelqu'un qui est effectivement racistes
antisémites négationnistes ou pu mettre
aux sceptiques j'imagine que dans une
université scientifique
donc je sais pas je comprends que je
comprends que ça pose un problème
ce que je comprends moins c'est que pose
un problème le fait d'empêcher quelqu'un
qui simplement s'est contenté de dire
qu'il avait le droit de parler
non mais moi j'en suis moi je ne suis
pas d'accord d'abord je suis pas
d'accord avec ses doigts sur la haine ça
c'est un autre pouvait pas de problème
ça nos débats non mais déjà je trouve
ces lois sur la haine
donnez des exemples d'abus de ces lois
ciné mer-mer il ya plein d'exemples de
gens qui ont été traînés au tribunal
parce qu'il avait dire un mot ciné c'est
peut-être le meilleur exemple signer a
dit que voulait botter le cul des femmes
voilées
il a dessiné une femme en france une en
train de se masturber avec un crucifix
dans le vagin et quand le fils de jean
sarkozy
on a annoncé que les convertir au
judaïsme pour épouser l'héritière de
darty il a juste recopier cette
information qui était paru dans libé il
a rajouté il ira loin dans la vie ce
petit c'est tout il était poursuivi pour
incitation à la haine et 807 charlie
hebdo qui est pas un journal
particulièrement modérée et donc je
trouvais ça très choquant c'est deux
fois aux et 3.273 pas trop mesure entre
ce qui peut dire des catholiques des
musulmans
et puis là rien dit sur les juifs il a
évoqué d'une conversion richard etter il
a gagné son père c'est différent mais ça
c'est vrai mais à partir de ces
associations le droit de poursuivre et
ça c'est le gros problème de l'europe
les 22 72
elles le font et à tous azimuts est il
prêt donner des tas d'autres exemples
mais évidemment après cinq ans peut
gagner avec des pros c'est un devoir
rassembler les signatures pour vous
soutenir et c'est pas exactement
agréable et ça a un effet dissuasif
c'est comme mon cas c'est comme le calme
ce soir c'est comme lille qui pas du
tout le monde c'est comme le cas de elie
atteignent encore moins nombreux c'est
pas ça la question
c'est qu'alors il ya tout le monde a
intériorisé l'idée quelque chose dont on
parle pas mais là on est sorti du champ
universitaire s'éloigne de nos
universités
comme le dit à toutes ces lois qui ont
été prises aussi au cours des dernières
décennies d'aidés des lois mémorielles
où l'homme politique a voulu écrire
l'histoire et c'est une réduction des
possibilités et c'est vrai que ça aussi
permet une coalition d'historiens de
tendances intellectuelles optique
différente contre ces lois mémorielles
et on va très bien à chaque fois le
processus où sa part d'un sentiment qui
apparemment dont il ya de défendre des
personnes ou de ou autres et ensuite ça
aboutit à une restriction non seulement
de l'expression mais aussi de la
recherche et on est
judiciarisation où effectivement les
choses se règlent au tribunal ou par
procès interposés le but étant de
terroriser les gens donc est aussi une
forme de terrorisme qui est appliquée
que d'une méthode d'ailleurs assez bien
rodé là où ses filles pardon c'est quand
ça se produit à l'intérieur même de
l'université quand vous avez par exemple
un président d'université qui traîne au
tribunal pour diffamation un
universitaire pour une plaisanterie qui
était évidemment une plaisanterie à
propos d'un homme politique
là on voit que ça commençait vraiment à
pénétrer à l'intérieur de l'université
d'ailleurs évidemment le président
universités en question a perdu et le
collègue a été relaxé y compris parce
que du coup on voit comment alors ça va
dans le sens de ce qu'on disait dans la
partie précédente
c'est toute une série de dispositions de
discours qui cherchent à attaquer les
protections dont bénéficient en gros les
chercheurs pour pouvoir justement ce les
empêcher de faire ou les obligés de
faire quand vous entendez la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche en france qui dit devant la
représentation nationale à propos des
présidents d université qui refusaient
l'augmentation des droits d'inscription
pour les étudiants étrangers
je cite de mémoire peut-être que je me
trompe mais en gros les présidents
d'université sont des fonctionnaires qui
dirigent des opérateurs d'état la notion
d'opérateur détails très présente dans
le discours du gouvernement actuel alors
qu'elle n'existe absolument pas dans le
code de l'éducation
et ils doivent obéissance et loyauté
alors qu en tant qu'universitaire ils
ont une protection constitutionnelle sur
leur liberté d'expression sur leur
indépendance
vous vous dites que dans l'esprit des
gens même de gens qui sont directement
dans la sphère de l'enseignement
supérieur et la recherche
on a l'impression qu'il ya des
protections qui ont sauté et là ça
commence à devenir beaucoup plus
inquiétant il ya aussi un confort mise à
part de beaucoup qui se couche devant
telle personne tels l'idée aussi pour
faire carrière donc le carriérisme étant
extrêmement présent être dans la
conformité intellectuelle est le
meilleur moyen d'obtenir tel ou tel
poste et de progresser donc ça c'est pas
nouveau je pense non c'est pas toujours
été présent à lui bien ça et ça a permis
d'ailleurs que prospère un état d'esprit
qui était promue au bénéfice et
exclusif quasi exclusif des hommes
blancs non mais je pense que c'est pas
inutile de le rappeler parce que
l'université est en train de subir des
attaques extrêmement forte alors qu'il
ya un changement générationnel massif
alors qu'il y à une féminisation des
métiers même si effectivement le statut
de professeur que j'occupe est encore
minoritaire parmi les femmes et au
moment où effectivement il y à une
pluralisation des points de vue qui est
en train justement de complètement je
dirais revivifier le monde universitaire
je suis particulièrement frappé par sa
cégépiens il ya une espèce il ya un
paradoxe entre ce moment où on voit des
refus de prise de parole des
interdictions de manifestations
et puis le faire quand on se trouve face
à un monde universitaire qui a
radicalement changé de visage de
physionomie il ya quelque chose de
complètement différent qui est en train
de se jouer
du point de vue des disciplines des
sciences humaines et sociales notamment
et c'est quelque chose qui en fait est
heurté de plein fouet par la réforme en
cours et par cette volonté par exemple
de disqualifier les critiques qui sont
faites à l'égard de certaines prises de
paroles c'est à dire au lieu de
s'intéresser aux raisons pour lesquelles
ses prises de parole sont empêchés et le
fait que par exemple fait qu'il ment un
moment donné on se dit bon toujours
offrir des tribunes à certains
adorateurs et ne pas en offrir à
d'autres ça finit par devenir un peu
voyant c'est ça qui fait que mirta
moment on va dire à françois hollande ou
à sylviane agacinscki wa rouiba la
figure cros et donc on veut pas les
entendre l'université wits ou connaît
vos arguments ou alors dans ce cas là il
faudrait aménager les espaces de façon à
ce que d'autres prises de parole soit
possible or ce n'est pas toujours le cas
parce que ce qu'on oublie et je pense
que c'est un élément important c'est que
il ya une forme de révolution
conservatrice qui accompagne la réforme
et qui fait que toute une série
thématique sont vécus comme étant
dangereuse parce qu'elles peuvent elles
ne sont pas forcément rentable elle crée
du 10 ans us comme si c'était un
problème à université qu'il y ait
effectivement des divergences de vue est
que cela alimente en fait la réflexion
et la recherche mais c'est vécu de plus
en plus comme un danger parce que en
fait l'université aujourd'hui doit
présenter une apparence lisse elle doit
être attractive
parce que sinon elle va pas attirer les
capitaux nécessaires pour avoir alors
même si on nous parle de 3% du
ib c'est ce qu'a annoncé la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur 3% du pib
dédié à la recherche on est très loin
d'en voir les effets et on sait que ça
va se passer sous une forme qui est
sélective
c'est la même logique dans le milieu de
la recherche que dans celui de la
liberté d'expression c'est à dire c'est
une liberté d'expression qui a de plus
en plus eu tendance à être sélective et
a cédé à des formes de pression et
d'intimidation
donc c'est aussi contre ça qu'à un
moment donné ce que ça va donner quand
il va y avoir des universitaires qui
seront des contractuels dont le contrat
pourrait être interrompue ils
bénéficieront plus des protections dont
bénéficient les universitaires
statutaire d'aujourd'hui sera encore
plus soumis à sa jambe en mai un exemple
en belgique qui dans mon université
d'anvers était nominalement catholique
et et roulantes ans était très
catholique vous pourriez pas dire ce que
vous pensez des indigents si vous en
pensez du mal mais récemment un
professeur qui est resté en cat audit
radis mercato comme comme l'église dont
la dir a dans un cours de philo est un
philosophe critique et l'avortement mais
d'un point de vue philosophique et ya eu
des plaintes d'étudiants qui ont été
relayés par des associations féminines
féministe et puis qui sont passés dans
les médias le profiter a reçu un
avertissement et son contrat il n'était
que temporaire n'a pas été renouvelé
lors été probablement sans cela et ça ça
m'a très fort choqué parce que ça montre
de nouveau le rôle de la société civile
l'université dépend pour son financement
du nombre d'étudiants ils ont pas envie
alors parce que tout a changé ils sont
plus du tout autre ils ont pas très
catholique
osons plus du tout catholiques et non
pas du tout envie d'une campagne faite
par des féministes disant voilà vous
êtes intolérants vous critiquez
l'avortement etc
moi j'écris un article avec un collègue
lui qui est très catho et qui est contre
l'avortement moi je suis pour mais je
dis ça m'a vraiment choquée que on
empêche monsieur pendant une heure dans
un cours avec des notes il n'oblige pas
les gens à répéter son cours il n'oublie
pas les gens à accepter ce qui dit ok la
limite je trouverais ça
un exercice de réflexion pour les gens
sont peu importe le mans c'est
intéressant de réfléchir à ces arguments
et le fait qu'on puisse pas se relâcher
requise a heurté les gens mangeaient et
et orthez toute ma vie et les
sous-entendus comme truc réactionnaire
pierrick tôt et tout ce que vous voulez
à l'université mais je pourrai pas aller
pleurer chez papa et maman exemple pas
gentil de sûreté est bon je trouve que
cette partie de la formation des
étudiants d'être heurtée et quand vous
dites que c'est néoconservateurs c'est
compliqué parce qu'annulant objective
entre certains milieux dits
progressistes comme j'ai dit rémy nice
est gbt hulu ou juifs ou etc qui
prétendait être progressiste et une
effective mans côté néo conservateurs
mais malheureusement je pense que la
gauche universités à la gauche un teckel
a une grande responsabilité dans cette
régression est aussi une grande impunité
à l'égard de faire du ski et casseurs
bloqueurs et autres cas on voit que les
étudiants qui le font ne sont jamais
sanctionnés
dans ces cas où les personnes sont
empêchés d'entrer à l'université de
s'exprimer parfois d'ailleurs de manière
violente
il ya il n'y a pas de sanctions à
l'égard de ces personnes station domaine
à la loi ça c'est vrai dans mon cas par
exemple le y avait un syndicat étudiant
je sais plus radicale jeu
non maintenant solidaire qui a dit qu'il
allait mettre le beurre j'ai appris un
nouveau mot le sbbl dans mon séminaire
s'ils avaient lu et vous vous êtes pour
qu'on puisse dire tout ce qu'on veut
je suis pas la coque un prof de physique
pour enseigner l'astrologie pas du tout
mais il ya une différence entre ce qui
fait danser cours et ce qui fait en
dehors de cette cour
c'est pour ça que j'ai donné l'exemple
de ce mathématicien qui il disait qu'il
serait ministre la culture c'est le pen
était président y a personne qui
l'empêchent de parler de maths ça dépend
ce que vous faites si bien drôle mais
par exemple
oui je pense que dans un coup de fil aux
pas il ya une très grande l'acccident
l'attitude ce qu'on peut dire dans les
cours de philo c'est pas super la corse
une incitation à la haine de quoi que ce
soit de critiquer l'avortement après
tout des théâtres des intérêts d'emprunt
pays du monde il est interdit
la plus grande partie de notre histoire
mais la période démocrate on est en
démocratie on parlait quand même si on
n'a jamais pu si on n'aurait jamais pu
défendre l'avortement quand il était
interdit on n'aura jamais changer la loi
donc il me semble que là il me semble
que effectivement mais quand vous dites
de trucs raciste sexiste tout ça il faut
s'entendre sur le sens des mots parce
que je suis pas d'accord par exemple
c'est sexiste de critiquer ouvertement
il faut buffet très précis sur le sens
des mots
et comme jeudi effectivement si on est
prof de physique en dehors de son four
si on donne un cours ordinaire de
physique et raon peut être assez sexiste
moscou voulait juste un petit en
demeurant les étudiants qui ont bloqué
je peux vous assurer que quand il ya eu
des entrées de police de la police qui
venait des blocages d'universités ils
ont été sanctionnés en physiquement mis
en garde à vue
il en subit les conséquences de leurs
actes soit dit en passant lors de ce
conflit actuellement la cette
mobilisation il n'y a pas de blocage la
logique précisément c'est d'occuper les
universités de faire venir les étudiants
et d'avoir des cours alternatifs de
façon à faire entendre d'autres voix et
sur ce que vous évoquez moi il me semble
qu'il ya quand même une difficulté
aujourd'hui à admettre que des formes de
prises de position qui ont défini une
forme d'autorité qui était très
verticale pendant très longtemps
aujourd'hui une des manières en fait de
démonter ce système là c'est précisément
d'exiger que des formes de prise de
parole qui ont toujours été admis ce qui
allait de soi en fait qu'ils n'ont
jamais été contesté le soir alors ça
peut sembler un peu violent la manière
dont ça se fait mais je pense qu'il faut
admettre qu'elles sont les dynamiques
qui se trouve derrière qui sont des
dynamiques qui effectivement conteste le
sexisme le racisme la domination de
certaines formes d'autorité se sont
toujours isolés mais sans contrepartie
ce sera le mot de la fin dieu sait si
c'est un débat qui risque de rebondir
régulièrement dans les années à venir
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]